[Music]
in computer love news submitted by
backpack backpack no from Dora how do
you know that's like my niece is here
wait door is a Mexican yeah yeah Dora
the Explorer Dora the explora every
little cute mexican girl in k-town looks
just like her I think she's Mexican cuz
she's always speaking Spanish she got
the Mexican outfit that's why I like how
we say every Mexican in k-town cuz
that's true Koreatown take away from the
source that I see I can't speak for all
Mexicans just the ones in k-town I see a
man who married his computer sues the
state of Alabama for refusing to
recognize the marriage Wow biggest troll
ever or is he serious I would love to do
that for a tax break marry my [ __ ]
computer yeah it'd be great I do it
right now but what is he gonna do like
in five years when it's all outdated
he's gonna want to know man that's what
every man has to deal with when they
marry a woman anyways right it's true
you marry it at the top of the line now
man are we talking about
I [ __ ] roll with that person whoever
how would you know nobody yeah so this
guy is dead serious so he claims to have
married his computer in New Mexico this
is this noise kinda confusing a little
weird like they recognize that a New
Mexico yeah so I don't know if they did
recognize it in New Mexico and I don't
know where he lives but apparently he's
suing the state of Alabama for refusing
to recognize the marriage imagine this
guy coming into City Hall and like
yelling at the top of his lungs just
like complaining and like I demand
respect
[Laughter]
and apparently he talked to Coursera
that I love my wife good Mack Mack
daughter into a robot doughnut mouth
yeah I mean what else could make a sex
machine dude you see blog dogs mouths
right look at that right it's just gonna
look like she's yodeling all the time
and apparently he's also filed similar
lawsuits in Texas and Utah and he filed
a suit in Colorado seeking to force a
baker to make a wedding cake for him
into his computer what is the Baker
taking a stand on that's I'm saying
why do Baker's take their job so [ __ ]
seriously all these kids are the only
people left you take the job that
seriously I refuse to make a cake where
again you make the [ __ ] cake it's a
[ __ ] King it's a king gay people eat
cake too this guy reminds me of all
those scam artists that those
handicapped guy is not going wheelchairs
and they're looking for businesses if
they don't have a ramp they're gonna sue
them if they don't have this bathroom
railing they're gonna see them like [ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] scam artists yeah yeah I
don't know that's why I'm so confused
I'm like there's so many states involved
with this guy New Mexico Alabama Texas
Utah Colorado
maybe he moves a lot he's like going
around bearing in every state and he was
also a former lawyer in tennis no oh
there we go yeah I knew if we gave him
gay marriage to do this [ __ ] I knew it I
called it he's probably like I called it
right didn't I call me because I love
that people were saying that [ __ ] back
in the wind member that it's like if you
give him gay marriage we're gonna be
marrying her bookcase next
Oh God I don't mean it holy [ __ ]
everyone Jesus mm-hmm yeah so he
identified himself as a
matimak penis Makena machinist machinist
I don't know whether to pronounce VHL
okay it's like that Christian Bale movie
I'm like I don't know how to pronounce
it
yeah really [ __ ] skinny in the
machinist read for the mechanist
that's the identifies himself as and
he's just saying that or he's alleging
that his rights along with the rights of
individuals his complete identifies as X
gay and X transgender were violated and
so that's why he is now suing the state
because they are not recognizing they
will not issue him a marriage
certificate I think he should die oh I
agree you know it's funny he's he's just
go along that quickly with us
unbelievably his arguments like you know
if you could marry a donkey in Alabama
why can't you marry a computer there's
just discrimination and he's gonna
protest no well they're saying that they
refuse to issue marriage licenses to zoo
files which are people that are in love
with oh they only do that in South
Carolina huh I don't know anyway yeah
they're files
machinist and polygamists they will not
issue marriage licenses to these people
so where can you go to get a polygamous
marriage license Utah Utah how does he
know the computer wants to marry him
yeah legal consent yeah cuz she didn't
go to jail for raping his computer but
she starts taking everything in and out
of it what the [ __ ] right I'll give him
the marriage licenses if he [ __ ] that
[ __ ] in the fan then I'll give him
whatever he wants
why is it he always if they forget in
the fan I have no idea no no no no I'm
trying to make it as challenging as
possible
this Chris he's a mother by making a sex
robot out of this noise and looking guy
why he has to be a troll can I see a
picture leaking never mind what he looks
completely free that's him in Utah you
don't have a picture of the computer no
no that's not the computer I want to see
him with this computer like this what's
his computer wearing a bridal gown or
whatever it is that the also I um change
wallpaper no no no cheese no that
wallpaper it's money in his filing he's
claiming that he married an object in
New Mexico with female like features is
what he he put in the file in that book
is feminine how is the computer female
like eyelashes on the top of the screen
like you do on a car like this is kind
of like your shoulder a little bit close
yeah who knows oh man if he wants to
[ __ ] marry a computer let him do it I
know I will not I put my foot down
I mean finally I'm put my foot down you
know what I was voted for gay marriage
alright I said let's do it but now I got
allow computers to marry people and I'm
not gonna do it I'll be the biggest
computer marriage foe but whatever what
about it supple wanted to marry a
doughnut because they like enjoy like
[ __ ] the whole team gets eaten he
needs to go to jail for murder
cannibalism that's right because he
killed his wife yeah
if he [ __ ] sticks his hand into that
computer and change the inside parts
[ __ ] murder scene so if the computer
dies there's there needs to be
investigation see this is where it all
this is what it all opens up though
because now there can be all kinds of
legal [ __ ] in all these states
frivolous lawsuits and all this [ __ ]
because some guys Mariners computer yeah
I mean what's the point of marriage now
besides the tax law like what kind of
benefits do you get when you die are you
saying like is that a Texan thing huh
insurance
visitation in the hospital wait how do
you say insurance insurance like people
we see it like people do you say
insurance oh no you said a little bit
more like how we think you said
insurance yeah you go insurer don't say
insurance
I deserved you it's on camera what kind
of benefits do get you get we finally
got her yeah sure maybe I heard you
wrong then it's not insurance you say
Plaza or Plaza huh chunk it like to
throw it away
yeah no no I don't but I've heard people
say it yeah she's too cool for that [ __ ]
do you say Texas or Texas even if it's
cactus cooler Mountain Dew it's still
cold yeah
coke oh yeah that's how it is in the
south really all right cool I want to
pop northern I lived in Ohio for a very
short period of time and everyone was
saying pop and I would just be like yeah
I heard that [ __ ] somewhere where the
whole thing in the glass
soda pop to me that's insane ways what
do we say here soda flavored seltzer
water DC soon some soda I would never
say Cola though no never
he says Cola I stopped making fun of me
cause I feel so must be really a Texan
thing for them to say insurance saying
that did you get insurance insurance
this this guy and Christina both make
fun of me all the time for saying hash
browns
barbel Berg a barbell Brigade this was
in barbell
are the best one what time is it what do
you mean it's like five five o clock
exactly man from the 1950s well how do
you say no oh because when you spell it
says five we know about that it's a
you're all weird about it
barber brigade enjoy some hashbrowns a
barbell what you want
I used to say uh what was it that you
guys who corrected me look at that I
never knew it was wrong place the word
it was a word that a lot of people use
that they think isn't work but it's not
in the English word what is it ya know
people say it a lot they think it's
smart Oh like conversation what happened
was no no I was just joking oh there was
another one I forgot I don't I'm not
done literally no that's a word I think
Julia had trouble thing literally dude
might possibly suppose that's pretty bad
actually I mean I grew up hearing that
supposedly I convinced my magical
friends entire family and her that on
the East Coast we say musk white house
we don't say mosquitoes and I did this
joke for a [ __ ] year well I was just
any regular conversation I'd be like
yeah I got bit by my squad no like
that's time and they're always like it
always like did something third brain
every time I said emulation well well
yeah I found out don't lie don't usually
lie too
yeah dude for a [ __ ] hear that I just
I just did it one day I was gonna
[ __ ] Yasmina [ __ ] and then I
decided to stick with it because it
really almost looks quite a little
[ __ ] that and I was like oh sorry like
on the East Coast really same yeah you
know you know when you just do a joke
and just continue it and just so there's
these two people that I know that I
convinced that they both like [ __ ]
funny to the disgusting but both of them
got drunk at a wedding and I was like
dude what and we just continued that
drug if he was like what the [ __ ] I told
him the same [ __ ] it's been four years
and I just continue with it constantly
and I just I don't know I never do I
convinced Nicky that I was colorblind
for a year as well I did this [ __ ] Rose
like knows like it's all over there by
the orange thing and she's like orange
it's not orange day that's [ __ ] red
it's red as day and I'm like oh I don't
know and so I kept on doing that like
with a daily life like I would do it
like once or twice a week
I just don't stop dude what else are you
lying about student right now I don't
have anything I would never be able to
trust me yeah yeah you know I don't do
that but but I did that for so long and
then one day I read when I revealed it
to her she cried and she was like mad as
[ __ ] yes you so mad for you
she had sympathy for me she thought I
was legit colorblind and I don't blame
her I get it the children she thought
that she was gonna have that really
colorblind you know what's funny
yeah these in that video with those kids
who are colored by they bring the
glasses and [ __ ]
what if they bought butter for you and
you're like
[Laughter]
so she would eventually be like like
she'd have to like try to walk me
through colors of things and I was like
yeah I gotta tell you I'm not a boy she
didn't believe me for like three days
that I that I'm not actually colored one
but then I started just drooling it like
okay it's dad and that and that cuz she
did a full on color blind test with me
one time too that I bow it's like it's
like your color blood if you see like a
cross in this pattern your color blood
and I was like or it's like if you don't
see if you don't see yeah yeah yeah and
I was like I don't there's nothing there
she's like you really don't see anything
that and I was like there's nothing
[ __ ] in there what the [ __ ] is your
problem there's nothing there there's
literally nothing then and then she she
she thought I was called by that's it
and then yeah that's [ __ ] fun and
that's how you get married folks hey
keep it keep it fun man what's up you
sexy [ __ ] useless [ __ ]
[ __ ] if you want to follow us you
could check out all our [ __ ] links at
the description box below you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and then that videos are up there
[Music]